l'aiguilleur du ciel trafic aérien
perturbé dès demain pour 10% des vols au
moins
andré bergeron le gouvernement doit
accepter une nouvelle réduction du temps
de travail nicaragua les guérilleros ont
gagné ils ont systems and à voir avec
les prisonniers politiques et une
dizaine d'otages
le conclave commence demain jean-claude
d'arrigo a visité les locaux où les
cardinaux vont être réunies messieurs
bonsoir nous allons dans un premier
chapitre de ce journal vous parlez
beaucoup retour depuis quelques heures
en effet les plages commence à se vider
paris les grandes villes vous attendre
mais ce ne sera pas facile d'y revenir
par la route comme par la voie des airs
le gros problème des retours par avion
vous le savez c'est celui que pose la
grève du zèle des contrôleurs aériens
qui ont décidé de radicaliser leur
position d'être moins souple qu'il ne
l'était lors du pont du 15 août
aussi nos reporters ont-ils l'enquêté au
ministère des transports à air inter
chez les organisateurs de voyages pour
essayer de vous préciser ce que sera la
physionomie de ces dix jours à venir les
négociations sont interrompues par la
grève du zèle et pour la troisième fois
le conflit est dans l'impasse
le ministre des transports a même durci
le ton en dénonçant je cite le chantage
exercé contre les passagers par une
minorité
cet après midi monsieur le peule a
encore une fois résumé sa position
d'abord je dois vous dire que dans ce
domaine il n'ya pas de grandes choses
qui valent quand quelqu'un fait gratuit
prend un risque
alors là il s'agit le fonctionnaire qui
ont une responsabilité de service public
l'état vis-à-vis d'eux à des obligations
mais eux ont des obligations aussi
vis-à-vis des passagers alors qu'ils
exercent leurs fonctions voilà ce que je
déborde et le mistral et transport et
ouverts à toute négociation j'ai rendu
public à l'aide d'ailleurs que j'aurais
envoyé qui fait le point nous avons vous
pouvez voir en lisant cette lettre de
tout ce dont nous avons discuté et vous
pouvez vous rendre compte aussi de la
médiocrité de la part qui est faite aux
questions de sécurité là contrairement à
tout ce qui est dit les questions de
sécurité ne sont pas mises en avant
lorsque l'on me braque sont mises en
avant lorsque vous entendez des micros
ou lorsque les caméras regarde le
gouvernement va demander de faire en
sorte que la circulation aérienne soit
régulière que les passagers n'est pas
souffrir j'utiliserai au fur et à mesure
des contraintes les mesures qui
paraîtront les plus justifié
vous appelle à des contrôleurs de
l'armée j'ai répondu un x ratinaud
n'était pas question je n'ai jamais
changé est féministe faudra bien
pourtant que la greffe fils un jour
c'est pas moi qui ai commencé la grève
les mesures que prendra le ministre sont
l'elysée l'a rappelé ce matin les mêmes
que pour le 15 août c'est à dire que le
gouvernement s'il le faut négociera avec
les compagnies l'annulation de certains
vols pendant la dernière grève du zèle
par exemple air france et iberia avaient
supprimé des liaisons et procéder à des
délestages au pire monsieur le theule
envisage la fermeture de certains
aéroports
d'autre part les aéroports de paris va
remettre en place le même dispositif
orly ouvert jour et nuit les bars et
restaurants fermés plus tard les postes
de la croix-rouge supplémentaire pour le
moment en tout cas
à la veille de la grève du zèle aucune
compagnie n'a nulle et de vol toutes
espèrent que leurs passagers n'auront
que de légers retards les conditions
dans lesquelles nous pourrons exécuter
ses valseront nous l'espérons les
meilleures possibles vous savez que le
week-end du 15 ou par exemple les
retards ont été relativement minime
la seule action que nous pouvons avoir
et nous l'avons car nous avons d'abord
le souci du passager c'est de mettre à
la disposition de ce passage est bien
sûr le meilleur accueil possible de tout
notre personnel et je crois que c'est
acquis mais en plus des moyens
supplémentaires d'information comme nous
l'avions fait le 15 août et des moyens
téléphonique d'information et nous les
tiendrons très au courant des attentes
d'éventuels où nous leur donnerons la
possibilité de faire prévenir les agents
de voyages par contre sont un peu plus
inquiet même si les chargeurs espagnols
ne sont finalement pas tous annulés ils
craignent de grosses difficultés pour
ceux qui partent vers les canaries ou
vers les baléares en passant par
l'espagne
m
nous considérons que 80 % à 90 % seront
acheminés par la voie normale avec un
certain nombre de décalages
naturellement qu'ils peuvent aller nous
le pensons maintenant de 1h à 3h 4h au
maximum il est possible que sur certains
aéroports de province nous soyons force
et d'acheminer un certain nombre de
clients mais en minorité vers des
aéroports espagnols notamment de
dégagement et à partir de ces aéroports
espagnols et bien nous organisons des
poids aérien vers les destinations
callari baléares et cetera en sens
inverse pour tous les vacanciers qui
rentreront d'espagne le système sera le
même si les compagnies ne veulent pas
survoler l'espace aérien français
les avions atterriront près de la
frontière à barcelone par exemple
et de là les agents de voyages les
acheminerons par autocar vers paris ou
vers les villes de province
de toute façon les frais occasionnés par
d'éventuels retards seront assumés
intégralement par les organisateurs de
voyages rappel cette grève est prévue à
partir de demain vendredi midi donc au
lundi 4 septembre vite
à l'issue du conseil des ministres le
porte parole de l'elysée pierre inde a
rappelé que tout serait fait pour
limiter les conséquences pour les
usagers de ce que l'elysée appelle des
pratiques abusives exercée par un
personnel réduit dans une période où le
transport aérien concerne le grand
public
ras de terre cette fois deuxième vague
de retours sur route
là aussi les obstacles sont nombreux il
ya d'abord les traditionnels bouchons
très rapidement je vous invite d'ores et
déjà les horaires déconseillés par bison
futé au départ de la bretagne et des
côtes atlantiques
demain entre 6 heures et 12 heures ainsi
que samedi et vous le voyez encore un
petit peu le dimanche au départ de la
côte méditerranéenne
la physionomie est quelque peu
différente mais ce sont ces heures-là
également qu'il faut éviter vendredi
donc entre 6 heures et 15 heures même
chose pour le samedi 26 entre 6 heures
et 15 heures deuxième obstacle
l'alcootest jusqu alors les contrôles
n'ont révélé que plus d'infractions mais
chaque région était prévenu par avance
les mobistes
sont assez partagés sur la mesure encore
qu'ils aient accepté là ses bonnes
grâces
l'alcootest en revanche les
restaurateurs les quartiers ce qu'on
appelle les limonadiers sont très courts
hausse et ils le font savoir bien haut
on les soupçonne ne peut être un petit
peu vite de toujours défendre d'abord
leurs intérêts financiers
pourquoi penser que les restaurateurs
fois souhaite vivre de l'alcoolisme
nous ne souhaitons pas le client e coli
ce n'est pas un bon client
si vous voulez que le français soit
vigilant sur l'alcoolisme c'est un sujet
sur lequel on l'a traumatisée il a dans
sa civilisation de boire du vin en
mangeant vous croyez moi que c'est
important il vaut mieux pêcher par excès
par excès de sobriété que l' inverse
je serais d'accord avec vous aussi nous
étions sûrs du résultat
les accidents de la route dus à l'alcool
is me représente quatre ou cinq mille
c'est quand même énorme
alors quitte à se priver de quelque
chose ou à priver peut-être une
profession d'une source de revenus à nos
menus autant taper très fort là où la
profession ne se défend pas de ses
intérêts dans cette affaire
la profession est consciente comme tout
citoyen qu'il faut lutter contre ce
grave danger que représente un homme
ivre au volant
quel serait votre slogan alors buvait
mais un petit peu
buvez à votre goût et à votre compte à
votre capacité
il ya des gens qui dépasse les 0 g 80
variétés cela est ce que vous croyez
vous avez les convaincre longtemps avec
ce procédé
et moi je vous dis que vous ne
convaincrez à l'heure actuelle que les
gens qui sont déjà raisonnable et déjà
convaincu troisième obstacle pour les
automobilistes est bien celui là est
beaucoup plus imprévues j'avoue que nous
avons été plusieurs à tomber des nues en
découvrant la formation voici s'il
s'agit de la condamnation de deux
automobilistes par le tribunal de grande
instance de par le duc dans la meuse
condamnation à 300 francs maman avec
inscription au casier judiciaire pour
publicité illicite en faveur du tabac
alors fait mérite de mots d'explication
wolf eyes est patrick cette publicité
illicite en faveur du tabac concerne en
réalité cette bande bleue que l'on met
en haut du pare-brise un pare-soleil
dessus il est inscrit le nom d'une
célèbre cigarettes brunes tension hta
publicités appelées vous pour les 24
heures du mans la dernière un contrat
avait été passé entre le constructeur
rené ligier et le seuil et alary et
tabac pour couvrir la voiture de
publicité pour cette fameuse cigarettes
et pour rentabiliser l'opération pour se
rembourser en partie des ses frais la
régie des tabacs avait envoyé aux
débitants de ses pare soleil à vendre
aux conducteurs qu'ils voulaient ainsi
se donner même avec une 2 chevaux des
allures de formule 1 ben alors à spa
c'est en septembre
un mois plus tard environ sont publier
les décrets d'application de la loi veil
pour la répression du tabagisme cnct a
dit à ce moment là nous avons donné des
instructions aux débitants de tabac pour
qu'ils cessent de vendre ses parts
soleil évidemment personne n'a songé à
prévenir les conducteurs qui avaient
déjà déposé leurs bandes et c'est ainsi
qu'aujourd'hui encore des conducteurs de
bonne foi d'ailleurs ils ignorent que
leur pare soleil s'ils les protège peut
d'ailleurs des éblouissements risque de
leur attirer la foudre des gendarmes
car il tombe sous le coup de la loi qui
prévoit ce genre damon et surtout
l'inscription automatique de se délier
du code de la route au casier judiciaire
alors ça fait partie de ces infractions
d'autant plus ignorer qu'elles sont
tombées dans les moeurs comme par
exemple pour les turfistes le fait de
donner son tiercé à déposer à au pmu un
par un tiers ça aussi c'est interdit
alors reste à savoir si le bon sens ne
conseillerais pas à ce qui donne
instruction aux gendarmes ne serait ce
que pour décongestionner les tribunaux
qui n'en peuvent mais à savoir si le bon
sens ne serait pas de faire enlever aux
conducteurs sur le champ la bande
coupable et puis le laisser partir
tranquille
la joute
dernière information à destination des
zones mobilis que la décision de faire
ou non ont baissé le prix de l'essence
ne sera prise que la semaine prochaine
au cours du conseil des ministres dès du
les ministres qui se retrouve
aujourd'hui au tour du chef de l'état
ont abordé le dossier de l'industrie
agro alimentaire
la france veut davantage exporter de
produits agricoles et alimentaires et
c'est indispensable pour sa balance des
paiements faut donc renforcer cette
industrie les ministres ont aussi
entendu le président exprimé sa vive
préoccupation devant la persistance de
la tension à beyrouth dans le sud liban
enfin dans notre deuxième journée la
soirée vous entendrez le porte parole de
l'elysée confirmé que la france a bien
demandé au pakistan de modifier les
usines de retraitement qu'elle s'est
engagée à lui construit il ya deux ans
afin qu'il soit impossible d'y fabriquer
un engin nucléaire
tout de suite après le conseil raymond
barre s'est rendu dans l'yonne dans une
petite bourgade de 6000 habitants
xinhua accueillie par le maire de la
ville le rpr jacques piot le premier
ministre a évoqué la réforme des
collectivités locales et la situation
économique
il ne s'agit plus de dire que l'on
dépensera n'importe quand n'importe
comment pour n'importe quoi et que les
moyens de financement suivant il s'agira
de maîtriser la dépense en choisissant
les dépenses les plus utiles
compte tenu des moyens de financement
disponibles nous avons à le faire à
l'échelle de l'état et nous l'avons
entrepris
c'est un problème qui va se poser il se
pose déjà dans un certain nombre de
collectivités locales il faudra bien sûr
prévoir les mécanismes d'adaptation et
de transition mais je souhaite vivement
attirer votre attention sur ce fait que
le développement des responsabilités
locales ne signifie pas la porte ouverte
à toutes les dépenses sans qu'il y ait
soucis de financement avec cette idée
qu'en fin de compte l'état fera lapointe
dans le dernier journal dernier claude
le commentaire de bernard prédit donc
sur ce voyage du premier dans l'yonne
demain raymond barre se rendra à
beaucaire dans le gard l'université
d'été des jeunes giscardiens du
mouvement autrement
une initiative de gabriel peyronnet
président d'honneur du parti radical il
souhaite que robert fabre prennent la
tête d'une liste radicale pour
l'élection du parlement européen et puis
la suite de nos rendez vous avec les
grands leaders syndicaux à la veille de
la rentrée sociale aujourd'hui andré
bergeron andré bergeron que jacques
merino et allait rencontrer dans le
quercy là où traditionnellement le savez
la général de force ouvrière prend ses
vacances
andré bergeron qui est revenu sur le
souhait d'une cinquième semaine de
congés payés sur les difficultés de
financement de la secte social mais
surtout sur le chômage
notre préoccupation dominante sera
naturellement le chômage et notamment le
chômage des jeunes
c'est un problème redoutable qui n'est
pas spécial à la france qu'on connaît un
peu partout dans les pays industrialisés
mais dans la mesure où le chômage des
jeunes prend la dimension qu'on peut
imaginer alors très vite
cela peut dégénérer jusqu'à la mise en
cause des institutions démocratiques
alors comment faire pour résoudre le
problème du chômage d'abord je l' ai
souvent dit les difficultés ont
maintenant un caractère universel
étant donné l'interdépendance des
économies nationales
mais cela dit on peut faire quelque
chose
je crois qu'il faut mieux adapter
l'enseignement aux réalités de la vie
donner une place plus grande à
l'enseignement technique dans
l'éducation nationale
revaloriser le travail manuel peut-être
faut-il aussi relancer l'activité dans
un certain nombre de secteurs en
difficulté et puis je crois qu'il faut
aller plus loin dans la discussion
portant sur la réduction de la durée du
travail
effectivement lors toutes les mesures
qu'on venait de deux proposés sont des
mesures à long terme qui demande du
temps
est ce qu'il ya des mesures que vous
pouvez envisager et qui a trait au terme
pourrait modifier son emploi
à mon avis le gouvernement doit
accepter une nouvelle réduction de la
durée maximum légal du travail
on doit remettre en question tout le
système des équivalences qui fait que
dans certains endroits on impose aux
salariés un temps de présence très
supérieur au temps qui leur est payé par
exemple ben dans les hôtels cafés
restaurants dans le commerce etc
et puis je pense qu'il faut débattre
dans les conventions collectives ou dans
les accords de type fonction publique et
secteur nationalisé de la durée
effective du travail
nous ne sommes pas les seuls de notre
avis le comité consultatif de la
communauté européenne du charbon et de
l'acier en évoquant les difficultés de
la sidérurgie a indiqué qu'il ne fallait
pas se résoudre à des licenciements
massifs mais au contraire examiner les
possibilités d'avancement de l'âge de la
retraite de réduction de la durée
hebdomadaire etc
et puis j'ai vu l'autre jour que les
commissions du plan se prononcer
exactement dans le même sens
par conséquent je crois qu'une réduction
de la durée du travail doit être
examinée immédiatement en vue de
parvenir à des solutions
sk semaine de 35 heures va devenir une
revendication de force ouvrière écoutez
je ne veux pas citer de chiffres
je pense qu'il faut aller dans le sens
d'une réduction progressive de la durée
du travail qui ne peut être la même
partout
étant donné la différence de situation
entre les industries et les régions mais
enfin sur le fond il faut aller dans
cette direction là l'actualité
l'étranger maintenant les opérateurs ont
beaucoup commenté notre entretien avec
le shah d'iran
nous avons diffusé hier soir tout le
monde a surtout été frappé par cette
sorte de lassitude physique et morale
qu'ils dégageaient des interviews
aujourd'hui nous donnons la parole à un
opposant du régime réfugie à paris
son argument numéro un le chat a tort de
dire qu'il porte le pays à bout de bras
qui les seuls à pouvoir contrôler la
situation
une des pièces maîtresses de la
politique de chasse était de dire moi ou
le chaos de dire qu'à part moi n'y a
rien en iran qui pourra assurer la
stabilité de l'iran et qui pour assumer
l'important c'est stratégique de l'iran
dans le monde actuel ce faux malgré 25
années de la répression l'opposition
iranienne démontre une vitalité
une unanimité et une capacité de
s'organiser et de formuler ses
déclarations politiques qui est étonnant
est-ce que les manifestations contre le
chah vont se poursuivre en iran jusqu'au
moment où il n'y a pas un changement
effectif des structures de régime en
iran les manifestations pour réclamer la
liberté la démocratie dont continue en
iran
mais le chat vient de promettre qu'il
allait démocratiser la promesse ne vous
suffit pas personne ne croira aux
promesses du chat c'est impossible de
croire à la libéralisation avec le
fringant
pourquoi je crois que le ch a démontré
au cours de sa vie plusieurs fois que
chaque moment difficile il a essayé de
passer en donnant des promesses c'est un
régime on voit en apparence si hier soir
on la voit à la télé française un vieil
homme larmoyante mais derrière et un
appareil de police politique intacte les
prisons sont toujours pleines de
prisonniers politiques
on arrête les gens dans la rue il y a
l'état de siège et la loi martiale
martial à travers plusieurs villes
d'iran comment est ce qu'on peut croire
aux promesses de libéralisation dans ces
situations il ya combien de conseillers
américains en iran actuellement il ya
les chiffres différentes qui sont
données
mais dans l'ensemble on peut dire qu'il
ya 35 à 48 conseillers américains
alors est ce que vous pouvez penser
raisonnablement que les américains
admettront un coup d'état contre le chah
j'ai à mon avis ça va être très
difficile pour les américains
en tout cas pour lironde qu'on assiste à
un coup d'état contre le shaq comme ça
soudainement à l'intérieur de l'armée
iranienne et je peux dire que pour moi
en tant que défenseurs de droits de
l'homme
c'est pas la meilleure solution est-ce
que vous avez le sentiment que le chat
serait prêt à se retirer si les
manifestations continuaient en iran en
tout cas ça je peux vous dire que s'il
se retire pas s'il s'en aille pas on va
assister en iran à des situations de
plus en plus difficile qu'ils pourront
mettre en cause la stabilité de la
région même le chat est devenu l'élément
de déstabilisation dans la région
il faut qu'il s'en aille pour que la
région est l'iran se retrouve sa
tranquillité de toutes dernières
informations nous dise que le premier
ministre iranien monsieur mahmoud égard
aurait remis sa démission en tout cas
présenté sa démission chat mais que
celle ci n'aurait pas encore été
acceptée nicaragua maintenant le
commando de guérilleros ce qu'ils
avaient investi le palais national et
qui retenait en otages plusieurs
centaines de personnes semblent avoir
gagné la partie s'il la veut gagner on
peut le dire ces exigences ont été
acceptées par le chef de l'état le
président somoza ils ont quitté le siège
du parlement en compagnie d'une dizaine
d'otages en majorité des parlementaires
et des personnalités proches du chef de
l'état et viennent il y a deux heures de
s'envoler pour le venezuela
voici les images de la libération hier
soir des premiers otages du commando du
front sandiniste
il s'agit des civils qui se trouvaient à
l'intérieur du palais national au moment
de l'assaut du commando
beaucoup d'entre eux étaient venus payer
leurs impôts leur libération a été
obtenue par l'archevêque de managua qui
a conduit les négociations entre le
commando et le gouvernement du président
somoza finalement le gouvernement a cédé
à la plupart des exigences des
guérilleros ce qu'ils ont pu gagner
l'aéroport et décoller il
deux heures pour lever des fonds le
commando était accompagné d'une dizaine
d'otages dont le neveu du président
somoza et des prisonniers politiques
dont il avait réclamé la libération
le gouvernement aurait versé une rançon
d'1 2 million $ au lieu des 10 millions
initialement demande réussite presque
totale donc pour le front sandiniste
dont le coup d'éclat parfaitement
préparée et exécutée aura fait céder le
régime du président somoza déjà en butte
à une agitation sociale très vive et qui
paraît plus vulnérable que jamais
enfin le dernier pôle d'intérêt pour le
d'intérêt à l'étranger et rome fall avec
bien sûr de l'ouverture du concile du
conclave les hommes d'église sont le
fait des hommes discrets et n a encore
filtré sur leur conciliabule d'avant
conclave seul un ordinateur a été un
petit peu plus délicat que il donne
comme favoris le nom du cardinal boggio
baggio par mail avant toute supputation
le décor décor spartiate que je voulais
moi c'est ici dans la chapelle sixtine
que vont délibérer et voter deux fois
par jour laissant aux cardinaux
électeurs du prochain pape toute trace
du décorum d'antan semble avoir été
éliminés selon la volonté de paul 6 + 2
days au dessus des sièges cardinalice
plus de tron
mais comme on le voit de simples chaises
mises les unes à côté des autres
on s'était demandé si l'un des lieux les
plus beaux de la chrétienté pourrait
accueillir pour le conclave un collège
de cardinaux considérablement agrandi
depuis jean xxiii la solution fut
trouvée en surélevant le sol de la
sixtine de 80 cm les cardinaux de
l'église romaine bon donc effectuer
l'élection du souverain pontife à la
fois dans le cadre grandiose des
fresques unique de michel-ange et aussi
signé des temps dans une extrême
simplicité
le poil qui a servi à brûler les
bulletins du précédent conclave a été
remplacé et mise à l'opposé de l'endroit
où il se situait précédemment afin de
donner aux fumées noires et finalement à
la fumée blanche des couleurs franches
et visible aux bulletins seront joints
des produits chimiques disposés près du
foyer
pour loger les choses près là il a fallu
équiper à la hâte pratiquement
l'ensemble du deuxième étage du vatican
les salles qui se succèdent à cet
endroit sont merveilleusement décoré
mais pratiquement inhabitables pour des
hommes d'aujourd'hui
la salle à manger commune équipée de
tables en formica recouvertes de nappes
blanches sera approvisionnée par une
cuisine située à l'intérieur du conclave
les vivres arriveront par un tour
pratiqué dans la double porte du patio
des borgia quant aux chambres des
cardinaux elles ont des allures
spartiate à peine le strict nécessaire
et ceci pour des hommes dont la majorité
a 70 ans et plus pour ce conclave lé
secret sera bien gardé on voit des
scellés par tous qui garantissent la
liberté de ceux qui demain éliront le
successeur de saint pierre
berciaud du conclave donc demain 17h 30
louise brown va bien louise brown c'est
ce petit bébé qui vous avez réveillé à
la fin juillet le premier bébé
éprouvette si bien louise a aujourd'hui
28 jours sommes maintenant en mesure de
vous présenter le film de sa naissance
pourquoi ce retard et parce que les
parents de louise avait passé un contrat
avec le gouvernement britannique et non
autorisé sa projection qu'au bout de
quatre semaines je vous préviens tout de
suite c'est une césarienne
ce sont donc des images qui peuvent
impressionner oui ces images datent d'un
mois mais qu'importe il s'agit d'un
document historique
vous voyez autour de madame brown le
docteur patrick steptoe qui va aider à
la mise au monde du premier bébé ou
pouvait pour lui cet instant est le
couronnement de douze années de
recherches menées avec le physiologiste
robert edwards et voici l'événement la
naissance de louise brown
son premier cri écoutez le devant ce
bébé loin des polémiques qui ont suivi
cette maison impossible
on ne peut que partager la joie de me
fier de ma mort et la fierté
ces deux médecins anglais
à l'étrier un mois après elle se porte
donc très bien en corse cette nuit
attentat contre la résidence secondaire
et le dépôt de meubles d'un commerçant
du continent installées dans l'île c'est
un commando du flnc qui a revendiqué cet
attentat
comme il ya deux semaines pour le
château de monsieur béguin près de
bastia est bien le commando a d'abord
fait évacuer les occupants de la
résidence collision entre deux cargos
sur la scène il y aurait quatre marins
disparus chez l'accident est arrivé en
début d'après midi à hauteur de caudebec
en seine maritime c'est un petit
caboteur anglais qui a littéralement et
prenez un navire ivoirien avant de se
retourner qui en l'air emprisonnant son
équipage dans une poche d'air
l'un des marins a été retrouvé par les
pompiers mais les autres sont toujours
bloqués il y en aurait au moins on vit
ici les sauveteurs ont dans les faits
repérer des coups frappés sur la coque
pour la quatrième fois de l'été les
guêpes ont tué la dernière victime met
en effet à un agriculteur de 57 ans qui
est mort hier matin dans le vaucluse et
il ne faut pas dramatiser les piqûres
mortels sont rares et l'intervention
rapide d'un médecin peut vous sauver
on voit soit des figures dans la bouche
ou dans la gorge provoquées par
aulombard une guêpe qui s'est introduite
occasion
avec un fruit là c'est grave ça peut
être gravissimes il faut un tube est
tout de suite et éventuellement
trachéotomisés et à côté de ça il ya
également un second type d'accident ce
sont les chocs anaphylactiques ici c'est
à dire c'est à dire une messe d'une
baisse de tension qui peut survenir chez
des gens qui ont été déjà beaucoup piqué
il ya théoriquement toujours un risque
ce risque malheureusement quand ils
existent et immédiat et donc s'il
faudrait revenir très vite
mais la plupart des piqûres se passe
très bien la page sportive du journal
football d'abord avec la composition de
l'équipe de france qui rencontrera la
suède dans neuf jours à noter vous le
voyez le retour de marius trésor et de
marc berdoll tous deux remis de leurs
blessures
l'absence de jean marc guillou et
bernard lacombe est en fait la
confirmation deux éléments d'une équipe
qui marche très bien en ce moment je
veux parler de strasbourg avec vous le
voyez guemriche et jouve à berlin-ouest
la razzia américaine continue après 16
finales qui ont été disputées depuis
dimanche 13 médailles d'or pour les
états unis dont 2 et 2 à l'urss une à la
république fédérale allemande 0 donc
pour les allemands de l'est à l'actif
des américains également cinq records du
monde la française annick de suzini
toujours elle s'est de nouveau qualifié
pour une finale celle du 200 m brasse et
les françaises du relais se sont eux
aussi qualifiés pour la finale 4 x 200 m
nage libre en battant au passage le
record de france
enfin le tiercé qui se courait à
vincennes dans le prix de sa voix la
combinaison gagnante le 8 le 7 et le 18
dans l'ordre pour 5 francs vous ne voyez
un peu plus de 57 milles francs dans un
endroit différent un peu moins de 6000
francs dernières pages du journal le
bulletin météo et je me tourne vers vous
laurent brault m d'abord pour donna
voyez bien imaginer une forteresse au
dessus de la france
une master show est stable dès que ni
des nuages s en approche
eh bien ils sont repoussés c'est donc du
très beau temps demain sur la france
après la dissipation des inévitables
brumes matinales sensibles en
particulier de la normandie à la flandre
et au nord de la seine et un peu sur
l'aquitaine mais assez vite et bien le
soleil réchauffera l'atmosphère et les
choeurs 25 30 degrés ce n'est même pas
placer le symbole des orages sur les
massifs montagneux est là
or ce ils seront rares en revanche
samedi et bien la forteresse va un peu
s'affaiblir
il y aura des nuages au nord de la seine
et sans doute quelques averses près des
frontières du nord
des orages plus nombreux sur l'est du
pays
ailleurs du soleil 22h50 sera l'heure de
votre dernier rendez-vous avec
l'actualité le journal sera présentée
comme d'habitude par et avec loeb
je vous remercie de votre attention et
je vous souhaite une excellente fin de
soirée